sam we've got some breaking news from
the department of health and social care
and that's about
travelers from france what is it so
you've been hearing all day long
warnings about imminent changes to what
you're going to have to do if you go to
france over the summer
they've just arrived let me outline
what's happening now you'll remember
just a few days ago ministers outlining
a plan to allow
returnees from ambulance countries like
france
being able to avoid quarantine if
they're double
jabbed from july the 19th in the last
few moments
the government has said this will not
apply to france in effect
creating yet another new category what
they say is that arrivals from france
must continue to quarantine in their own
accommodation
or in a hotel and take tests on day two
and and day eight let me just unpack
that for a moment
the danger was that france was going to
be moved from the ambulance to the
uh to the red list and what that would
mean would be mandatory
hotel quarantine spending thousands of
pounds on hotels
in order to protect people and make sure
the virus didn't come over from france
even though
case rates are quite a lot lower the
government have decided not to do that
and just implement a system of mandatory
home quarantine so it's the same
situation if you'd only had one vaccine
that
this would apply uh to you uh would have
already applied to you now this will
apply
uh from july the 19th if you'd had two
vaccines as well
this will be a big blow to people who
are planning holidays
in france it's not perhaps quite as bad
as if they had to pay for the hotel
quarantine
but will still be massively disruptive
for people uh
announced late on a friday night i think
it's just before the summer holidays
school summer holidays i think the
timing uh having downing street
done very little to prepare people for
this uh not really engaging in public
about what this is happening now
uh we've had some statements from key
ministers grant shaps
says travel will be different this year
and while we're committed to opening up
our priority is to protect public health
here in the uk uh and sanji javid the
new health secretary saying
uh we have always been clear we'll not
hesitate to take rapid action at our
borders to stop the spread
of coving covid19 so a
huge number of people tens possibly
hundreds of thousands of people now
having to re-evaluate their plans for
the next
uh few weeks no doubt there will be
anger from travel companies and from
tory back benchers at this
um i suspect that mps will be wanting
quite a lot of explaining for ministers
because
uh the british case numbers are eight
nine times the french case numbers
it's not clear what the justification uh
uh for this
uh is and they've also fudged their own
categories one more
time adjusted the rules to fit the
situation uh suggesting that the
original classification of green amber
and red not fit for purpose so i suspect
there will be an
awful lot of irritated people this
evening